[Musique]
ce jeune garçon s'appelle philippe
chatel il a 22 ans il chante fort bien
et chante ses chansons puisqu'il est
auteur compositeur il vient de sortir
son tout premier disque graphique chater
un premier disque qu'est ce que ça
représente pour un jean
ça représente beaucoup d'espoir ça
représente aussi beaucoup de travail
pour arriver à faire un point me dise
pas ce qu'on m'a séduit bien qu'il y en
a beaucoup qui sortent il faut quand
même faire beaucoup de choses pour faire
un premier disque ensuite on a
l'espérance qui veut marcher
il faut qu'il marche celui-ci marche pas
c'est pas très clair enfin de toute
façon son expérience très intense mais
vous pensez faire une carrière vous
pensez de ce métier ça sera votre
carrière
parce que celle ans c'est un petit peu
ça le premier disque marché puisse adema
oui m'enfin je pense que quand on
commence toute chose c'est pour aller
jusqu'au bout vous êtes plutôt enfin
vous êtes plutôt sombre à sète une image
qu'il faudrait changer
il faudrait effacer non je suis pas son
fils dans la vie non je pas du tout
triste mais je suis assez réservé c'est
la timide oui je suis assez timide
alors je me dévoile pas si facilement à
l'interview d'autres d'autres oiseaux
figurent des choses très drôle
dites-moi fiche chatel le mois d'août
c'est quoi pour vous leur correspond à
quoi bon mois d'où ça correspond tout ça
c'est pour la chanson était d'août est
le mois d'où ce correspond à
en vacances pas sa crainte parce que ça
correspond pour tout le monde c'est les
vacances l'été il fait chaud une
certaine décontraction quittera la
chanson c'est un solo de thé pour danser
[Musique]
douze mois tout
e
[Musique]
d'où pour toi
hautmont
[Musique]
dis moi de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi
deux mois
ta main
[Musique]
dur
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaud
chaud chaud
je
[Musique]
où
toi
pour toi
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]